Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
It was announced recently
that Matt Reeves would be introducing
Robin during the Batman 2,
along with another new major
villain from his rogues gallery.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Most of you probably seen some Robin
talk in your feeds recently.
I know everyone's been fan casting.
Timothee Chalamet is a version of Robin.
He did talk about being Robin a while ago.
But are you're working
with that different?
I was going to say
Robert Pattinson, new Batman.
Do you think about Robert Pattinson
as it's going to be awesome.
I think it's going to be awesome.
I don't I
you know, I think it's going to be great.
The Greg Frazier, an Australian DP,
he did Dune.
He's shooting the new Batman.
So it's going to be awesome.
And I just know it's going to be fresh
and I don't know what direction,
but I think
it's going to be a great new thing.
But I grew up, you know,
you can ask my mom, who's here?
People in the elevator
growing up just ask me like, well,
you know, if they ask me what question
if I was like five years old,
what's your name? I say Robin.
And and actually every director
steered away from putting Robin
into well, actually,
Zack Snyder had a flashback of Robin,
but it was like 3 seconds.
And I even know if it was Robin by name,
But they steered away from it
because it's like,
I don't know, it's hard to do dramatically
or something a I'm not averse to that,
you know, those universes,
after seeing him in Dune,
he could actually do a pretty bad
as Robin.
But the thing is, though, the report
is that during the Batman to Matt Reeves
is going to introduce a version
of Dick Grayson who is only 13 years old.
end, even though Timothy Zalmay does
look pretty young, there is no way, no way
he could pass for 13 years old.
So pretty safe bet
that he's not going to be the new Robin.
but this would be the first time we've
seen a live action Robin, in the movies.
At least
they've had one on Titans for a while now
or a couple of versions on Titans.
in specifically a version in the movies
who is alive because Zack Snyder
did introduce a version of Robin
during Batman versus Superman.
But it was Dick Grayson, and he was killed
before the events of the movie.
that was meant to be this untold history
that he had with Joker and Harley Quinn
that they kind of alluded
to during the first Suicide Squad movie
and then later during the Justice
League, Snyder cut with their post-credits
scene where he was taunting Batman
in that post-apocalyptic future.
So this new version of Robin
that we're going to see
will be the first living version
that we've seen in the movies since Batman
and Robin with Chris O'Donnell's
Robin in George Clooney's Batman,
who we also just saw
at the end of the Flash movie
him messing up the timelines again
at the end of that movie,
basically crossed over the Clooney verse
timeline with the main Snyder verse
Justice League timeline.
So technically, Chris O'Donnell's Robin
is now canon to those movies as well,
even though James Gunn
is rebooting everything
with new actors
in a totally different Earth.
and he's got the Damian Wayne version
of Robin debuting in the Batman Brave
in the Bold movie in a couple more years
with a totally different Batman.
That'll be the crossover
Justice League Batman.
So the easiest way
to think about this going forward
is that Matt Reeves Batman movies
with Robert Pattinson are all meant
to be Elseworlds per James Gunn
the DCU is connected
in film, television, gaming and animation,
that the characters are consistent,
played by the same actors,
and it works within one story.
And if something is outside of that,
like Matt Reeves, Batman
or Todd Phillips, Joker or Teen Titans go
that it is clearly labeled
as DC Elseworlds outside of the mainstream
DCU continuity.
They'll continue making Matt
Reeves Batman movies and his spin off HBO
shows like the Penguin episodes
they're working on right now.
And they'll just be Elseworlds Right now,
the Penguin episodes
are supposed to take place during Batman
Year three, charting the timeline,
the events of the Batman two
will take place about a year after that.
So Batman Year four basically
he'll have had a couple of Batsuit
upgrades, Batmobile upgrades
generally upgraded tech all around.
And if Matt Reeves is introducing
a 13 year old Dick Grayson,
that means will probably see
a version of his comic book
origin just updated to fit
with the other changes
that Matt Reeves made in the first movie
with the characters.
Good example is the way he changed
the Riddler's
origin story and connected his backstory
more with Bruce Wayne's backstory.
Like the orphanage started by Thomas
and Martha Wayne, the Wayne Foundation
that he worked for, how he was basically
like an accountant working for the mob
then eventually decided to seek out
his own justice against everyone.
the version of Dick Grayson's origin story
during Batman Forever is pretty close
to his comic book origin story.
He grew up as a circus performer
with his mother and father.
They had a group
called The Flying Graysons
and performed a trapeze act until
one night they were performing in Gotham.
His parents died in an accident.
Bruce Wayne was in attendance
and decided to make him his ward
and take him in the big difference
between Dick Grayson
and the other main versions of Robin,
at least Jason Todd and Tim Drake.
Not necessarily Damian Wayne,
because he was his biological son.
but Dick Grayson is the only Robin
who Batman took in
who wasn't his biological son
that he never adopted.
when they started doing this
with the later versions of Robin
in the comics, fans
started asking this all the time.
Like, why didn't he adopt Dick Grayson?
Like the later versions of Robin?
They finally canonically answered
this question
in the comics and tales of the Teen
Titans Number 15, 1984, he asked Bruce
if he ever thought about adopting him,
and Bruce answers that he was too young
at the time and too obsessed
in the beginning of his career as Batman
and never really thought about it
at the time, Which sounds exactly
like Robert Pattinson's
current version of Batman, like Matt Rees.
During the events of the first movie,
he wanted him to feel like
he was totally obsessed with being Batman
to the detriment
of all other aspects of his life.
that's why Alfred had to force him
to meet with the accountants
at Wayne Enterprises,
because the company
was going down the tubes
because he was neglecting it in favor
of spending all of his time
as Batman each night
and basically just skipping out
on any Bruce Wayne aspects of his life
when he appeared in public
during the mayor's funeral.
That was meant to be a huge deal,
like he hadn't
shown his face in public in a long time.
And everyone was super
surprised to see him like, Oh,
you're finally showing your face now.
and speaking of Robin, there were
a lot of people who saw that funeral scene
where the mayor's son and Bruce Wayne
kind of lock eyes for a very long time.
and people thought at the time
because they released this clip
before the movie came out,
just completely out of context,
that it was meant to imply that the kid
would become a version of Robin.
But that's not the case.
This was meant to be the mayor's son,
a totally different person.
They're going to cast somebody
totally different as Dick Grayson,
and it'll be more like comic book Robin
when Batman first
took him in in the comics,
he didn't take the actual mantle of Robin
wearing the suit,
going on missions with him
till after they spent a bunch of time
training together,
So it's pretty likely that Matt Reeves
will introduce the character,
give him a version of his origin story
where he becomes an orphan.
At some point in the movie, Robert
Pattinson's Batman will take him in in
the kid will discover
that he's really Batman,
and eventually
Batman will agree to train him.
maybe they just tease him
becoming Robin, getting the costume,
or maybe they teased their training
at the end of the first movie
and then by the events of the third
movie, like the Batman three,
whatever that winds up being.
Then he debuts in the actual
Robin costume.
let me know in the comments
who your fan cast is for Robin,
if he's only going to be 13 years old
when the movie
The other big news is that Matt
Reeves is supposed to introduce Clay Baze
during the movie,
but he's not going to be the main villain.
Most people think that he's
going to be a version
of the original Clayface,
the Golden Age version.
The character called Basil Carlo.
not the shapeshifting metahuman. Clayface.
Matthew Hagen.
That's who most people think of
when they think of Clayface.
the reason why everyone's expecting
the original Clayface is
just because he's more of a real world
down to earth, kind of Clayface.
And that's the whole vibe of the Matt
Reeves Batman universe.
so far, we haven't seen any actual
metahumans in the world of the Batman yet.
So everything's been tech based,
at least so far.
The Basil Carlo Clayface was based on real
life, Boris Karloff and Basil Rathbone.
Carlo was meant to be a B-list actor
driven, insane
when he hears that they're remaking
his classic horror film without him.
during that movie, he played the villain
who is called Clayface,
and he puts that costume back on again,
killing all the actors who are
in the remake in the order that they got
killed in the original movie.
then eventually Batman
and Robin are able to stop him.
Don't be surprised.
They update his origin story
just a little bit
because they changed the Riddler's
origin story,
But they don't have to update
Clayface is origin
that much to make it fit
within this current universe.
they haven't revealed who the main villain
is supposed to be hoping for. Mr.
Freeze,
Matt Reeves talked about this a while ago,
So a lot of people at the time
thought that an implied that Mr.
Freeze would be the main
villain Matt Reeves just said
even the idea of something like Mr.
Freeze. Such a great story, right?
So a lot of people were like,
Wait a minute,
does that mean he's actually doing Mr.
Freeze in the sequel?
The monster who took you from me
will soon learn that revenge is a dish
best served cold and they also implied
that they might be doing Court of Owls
at some point,
not necessarily in the sequel,
but at some point during this Matt Reeves
trilogy of Batman movies.
there were a lot of Easter eggs
and references
to the Court of Owls
during the first movie.
That's why the actors
were talking about it, like, yes,
there was a lot of court of appeals
in there.
Thomas and Martha were leaders
of the Court of Owls in this timeline.
Like that one.
Oh, that's of
I was definitely kind of thinking
it's probably going to be in the sequel.
It definitely seems nice. Mommy,
I'm not sure.
Just guessing, I guess.
Keep saying
good thing it's not in this film.
Or is it?
Or is Let me know in the comments, though.
Who do you want to be
the actual main villain of the Batman to
do more Batman videos
when we get more details.
And James
Gunn won't announce his Batman in Batman
braving the bolt until after the Batman
two comes out with Robert Pattinson.
They don't want to steal
any of their thunder,
so it'll be a while before we will learn
about that other version of Batman.
As far as I know, Andy Muschietti is still
directing Batman and Brave in the Bold,
even though everything is paused
by the strikes right now.
You know, there are a lot of complaints
about the Flash movie just in general.
one of the best aspects of that movie
was the way he treated
both versions of Batman in their action
on screen, like he actually did.
Really did
a good job of Ben Affleck's Batman
in a good job of Michael Keaton's Batman.
So even if a lot of people
were disappointed
by the actual flash of it
all in the overarching story,
the Batman stuff,
and it was actually pretty solid.
Ben Affleck
even said after he did his scenes
that he actually wanted
to come back a little bit,
even though he had told them
that he was done as Batman at the time
And it's my best I've done as
I finally figured out how to play the guy.
No, really got it.
I was like, Hold on. Is that I quit.
I know I quit.
And I know I can back it,
but I got it now.
And it helps you.
It helps you see the character, and now
you want another chance to play it.
And I was like, Wait a minute, I got it.
Am I still with Can I guys?
So really, can we write another story?
Am I there's a bunch of big stuff
coming up next week.
My full Ashoka Episode 4 video
will post after they release it.
If you have any special requests
for bonus videos, just let me know
in the comments below to Click here
to learn about all the Superman
deleted scenes, the whole alternate
ending during the Flash movie,
and click here for that
Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!